here
hi everybody hi Kelly Clarkson Hi how
are you I haven't seen you in 20 years I
I'm literally so excited about this I am
disappointed in myself because you know
how near show you had the thing to come
out for people with a short like yes
that was one of my favorite things about
your show because I'm so short and I we
need to work on that yeah yeah it was a
good thing although once William Shatner
was there and it malfunctioned and he
was his feet were I guess not touching
and all of a sudden he slid down right
out of the chair on live TV well that's
kind of funny yeah it's funny for a
moment but I was worried as an elder
gentleman you know there goes William
Shatner's back I just killed William
Shatner that's amazing which you don't
want to do uh we haven't seen each other
you said 20 years you know if you
remember
okay because I was I actually went back
and looked at the interview because I
was like I know we ran into each other
but I was so annoying because I was
nervous but I was so nervous because I'm
such a look at my smile I'm so excited
I literally like every time someone says
because I never thought I'd have a TV
show but it was interesting I connected
with you and you're such a fan of things
yes and you're like a true fan like I'm
hoping to like emulate that a bit well
you did say to me I don't know if you
remember you said I hope to have a
career like you I did I did you did say
that to me but what's funny is I didn't
mean like a talk show I meant longevity
right yeah I was yeah I was I didn't
even mean that and I said to you you're
gonna I know it I didn't hear you are I
know thank you it was me yeah
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody
[Music]